yeah hello and welcome to this video
about round five round five that's game
five right I met you you're not do it in
rounds yeah Game five of the World
Championship match between magnus
carlsen and sega coyoacán yeah that much
really has some yeah improved a lot over
the last games first two games were
really boring in Game three and four
really big fights where I'm cars and had
a huge advantage in one case also clear
winning continuation in Game three but
didn't manage to break through and yeah
we have four draws up to this game and
game five also was a good one can tell
you that that much in case you haven't
seen it yet let's get going here and we
have another 45 um and Carlton now goes
for the Italian game I was actually
surprised surprised maybe um to learn
that the last time this opening was
played in the World Championship game
was in 1981 my Karpov when at some point
you didn't have anything against the
courts open Spanish open road Oh pass
and before that we have to go back like
to the yeah like 100 years earlier
evening 1800 something um probably by
the chicken or somebody like that
surprising and nobody played it just
even as a one-off alternative yeah the
tying game has become popular in recent
recent years one reason is that the
Berlin is so incredibly solid so they
try other things and yeah okay kayaking
goose Bishop c5 on that level they don't
risk this line I mean forward
championship match that would be really
risky to play yeah get the sacrifice a
pawn and so on yeah Bishop c5 is played
and cars and goes with castling this is
already a small order finesse the
traditional way of doing this is c3
96 and now III my just going for a d3
base set up here those old lines with d4
basically played out to equal positions
or if wide risks too much even worse
positions 4 wide they are the
interesting thing is in this situation
the MOOCs III um is generally useful for
wide but not so much in one particular
scenario in this scenario is this one a
black breakthrough in the center quite
quickly this line has gained momentum in
recent times and here it is not clear if
the structural white actually needs the
porn on c3 or rather on the contrary
would be happier to have it on c2 we
will see a similar situation being
possible in the game and you will see
that probably this is not the most
useful move in this position so Cass
castles first night of 63 black castle
and now it's card this move if you go
see three be 0 transpose to that other
move order but instead he plays the move
a form this is um getting more and more
popular in the Italian game that early
a4 move if you watch my blitz games and
you will probably remember that I'm
struggling with black against the setup
as I simply hasn't they don't understand
it it seems it seems to be the main
problem i'm happy that i understand i
hope most of this game that we don't
didn't get something where I'm saying no
idea um yeah okay a4 if black now goes
d5 and this is something that has been
tried um yeah white will play that
groupie one next and put pressure on d5
here is actually quite useful that you
have not played the move c3 this then
you will recognize in cases for example
like this when I'd be six if you move
the bishop now yeah you're not
potentially leave this hanging on d3
just a one possible reasoning here um in
fact I'm here there are some tricks
around and I found it game here
is very just very quick a game like that
between Greece shock and some person
called mock me off I think it's a blitz
game but says it features a funny tactic
c3 and our black played the move age six
and that failed to send a tactic if you
want to make a small exercise all of it
yeah I pause the video and look for
yourself right now yeah gets a big
advantage probably winning advantage
with the move Bishop takes h6 funny
detected so digs digs and clap that's it
now what essentially wins the pawn & age
6 is a pretty important one it's funny
that you just played h6 at the end okay
I'll take it then die slow tactic to
remember um okay in the game kayak in
just 26 that's the conservative and I
think probably best move now c 3 and
here this position has been discussed
quite a bit on the top level and the
main question here for black is a six or
a five by this threatening and b form
and a five minute apiece so if i cannot
just do whatever Bishop strapped so he
essentially has to move the a porn I I
often play or not all I play a six in
this position and kayaking does the same
as I generally play a six and in all
kinds of Italian games to give this
Bishop Square and I was always skeptical
about the a5 move because it weakens the
queenside however i have to say that I'm
always struggling in the a six positions
and I have this suspicion maybe a five
is so it's a very very good alternative
but i have to say that I'm probably not
the best advice here because I'm
struggling with black and this kind of
in this kind of structure and um I'm I
don't I don't feel I
I have understood the subtleties really
well and this what it does here five is
clearly it stops any expansion on the
queenside on the other hand down is
square it usually it continues like that
by the way and um I mean I always have a
hard time to believe that black is in
trouble in these positions but maybe
this is my problem there that I'm just
not getting it right yeah so p6 was
played in the game and before is a
obvious move here on one of the obvious
most interesting as Bishop g5 you going
for pin and yeah this has been seen
recently most notably in a game that
I've not really really funny like this
and now G for this was played in a game
between the younger man master yang
Christian Schroeder and no offers in
there from France yeah and shrewder here
played the stunning new bishop age for
me it has simply ignoring the threat to
this night and there are some
interesting ideas nowadays in those
quiet openings right yeah black now
essentially has to take otherwise he's
in this in this awkward pin so takes it
King g7 yeah and now White has a pretty
comfortable situation it can actually if
he desires I just make a draw emphasis
sir just a repetition black has to cover
this this night but you can also
continue as sure they did and mean he
was confident to continue as he runs
some pretty little risk something like
here and just building up and he got a
winning position a little bit later I
don't want to analyze the game in all
that all that detail it's not our main
main concern this is how it went and
yeah he had like Age 3 M gave why did
fantastic
the king it's difficult for black to get
out of this so it ended in a row by the
way but the position was very good so
Bishop g5 is a good alternative before
you should SF rupee 197 a very common
maneuver the night is not well placed on
a sorry on c6 it looks at covered
squares mostly and likes to go to g6
also allowed to places and so that looks
completely automatic deform and now see
six step again a very very normal move
taking some squares under control and it
also prepares a d5 d5 move instead black
could have taken actually and played d5
this is what I initially thought would
be quite ok for black it's an this kind
of transformation is what I often try to
get there in this position to have a
clear structure to play against this
pawn however here wide with b5 retains a
very annoying initiative I think this
position is actually pretty difficult
for black am Bishop e3 is coming queen
bee three is coming so not that he's in
terrible shape but it's not a
comfortable position at all I think I
Atkins mu vs is good simply c6 um age
dream by Carlton yep Bishop g4 was a
potentially annoying pin this kind of
belongs into the position and now okay i
can took on deform widen captured with
the pawn and 19th before very
interesting decision leading to a
transformation of the whole structure
and the move d5 comparable to to to this
earlier suggestion also was certainly
coming into consideration after the
capture on d5 which is my it's not
mandatory Bishop d3 is a matter neither
form yeah yeah probably wide will take
and here as he takes is probably am
the move to go for you have to be quite
alert here if you do something like that
they're white could all of a sudden get
a pretty vicious attack taking on before
is the real mistake there but we black
can do this and I don't think white has
much in this position I mean it's very
symmetrical and blacks pieces look fine
to me all this is round equal this is an
interesting choice not XD form the
accounts now whenever Bishop takes f7
and um yeah really got the position very
very not symmetrical or controversial
instead I think this wasn't too bad at
all yeah just to allow the fork and
transpose into this position may become
I'll estimated this position because if
you the check it a little bit with with
engines black is under some pressure and
maybe or maybe here valuated it like
that by thought ship f7 would be better
this is this is not all that easy here
for black this is the key idea and black
is is suffering a little bit at least
for example um ya hear something like
takes takes 55 and turn yeah something
like that isn't all that easy for black
to play it's a little bit awkward c6 is
a bit weaker than deform I know I mean
white is better but is it something
that's going to bring you a game that's
maybe a very questionable maybe cousin
saw this kind of position thought okay
this is just too little not challenging
all that much but it's not fun for black
really it's not fun you have very little
that you can do and also note that this
night is not particularly graded if the
night I mean the night rather wants some
wants to be somewhere else on d5 oil is
60 yeah and whenever you move it does
maybe 90
five and Bishop e3 Elizabeth that comes
with the tempo it's not not that clear
here how black completely equal I this
is so that was a decent alternative clap
ya over this happened and now okay I can
25 this kind of invites the night to see
five so you could maybe question this
move however i think it is perfectly
fine the night on c5 isn't the end of
the world and alternatives aren't that
great yeah i mean they are playable
something like this for example but i
think he was writing going d5 here white
actually has an interesting this
interesting idea b5 it took a moment for
me to understand what the engine is all
about with this move but it makes some
sense if black takes em for example in
such a situation the move Queen to be
three will become quite annoying and
with 95 coming why combination of queen
bee 395 yeah and also if black captures
this way further queen bee three if we
for example assume black would take 3
p-3 and we've got this and this is a pin
in some way and the bishop cannot so
easily move and not a very comfortable
position for black so I know Bishop f5
is probably not that great there's also
this move on Chanel 5 which is probably
equal ish I think d5 is fine the our
cart opt in to see five of course and
this is not a good square the night has
no we're back it has no no return ticket
let's say like will not blunder the rook
and the thread is aged six now it's it's
quite quite uncomfortable I mean the
computer actually yeah gives us oops not
there it gives this idea where this is a
completely inhuman way to play and it
ultimately doesn't
too much so 95 is of course what you
wanted um okay h6 that's useful and then
move 95 not for Queen here and I'm sorry
ya hear all those things age six
perfectly reasonable move rook a three
again a good movement the bishop on c1
is already developed it can stay there
and the look now will be used on the
third-ranked push it a five and no much
not much commentary needed their next
move maybe counsel could have improved
and this is an idea that Peter swidler
mentioned in his in his broadcast I
think I not sure maybe it well suppose
Eric hands and I watched the broadcast
on it off and a five is to move play
this now I mean contemplate Knight to e5
but maybe a five wasn't interesting
maybe it was a good option probably
because there are they will be scenarios
where 86 285 it's a tricky thing for why
to handle and a five stops those ideas
once and for all you will immediately
recognize and if you look at the game
continuation 95 horse plate takes on
takes Queen edge for it was played in
the game and now you see here this is
hanging and 85 is an idea now
undermining the this is outpost if you
compare this to a five it's actually not
quite clear what blacks movies and maybe
play something like that and that's that
is what the computer suggestion and it
looks logical if white goes for the same
thing now we would actually get the game
position with white having gained to
10.5 and this is quite useful and so
that you don't have to worry about a six
to a four from black you play this
however immediately takes and now pawn
takes as I said and rook takes was a
possibility but clearly not very
ambitious
and the Carlton wants to fight here and
they actually both played quite quite
quite a fighting spirit up job to here
and the next couple of moss and this is
a possible move but it ultimately
doesn't lead to much it's just not um
let's say doesn't put put any pressure
on black if you take with a pawn you at
least have a passer your black is okay
with the simple move Queen evade you
know the idea is if you play it um what
should should explain that if you play
here to attack the rook kick it out
there is 97 the situation is actually
not all that clear and it's a playable
move yeah but should be aid the ideas
that here you have this kind of
situation here black still has to be
quite annoyed because of this weekend
Kings side um it's not ever completely
unnecessary to go there if you just play
here as mentioned you'll find the Queen
lens this additional cover to this and
up to something like this variation
black is perfectly okay I mean this has
got no problems this is covered you
maybe can move the rook and later cover
this if you want or if everything else
fails just heck the night off so here
black is also fine so this is more
interesting Queen edge form is probably
the best move it's the most aggressive
also and it actually gives white only
yeah white only has one really playable
move now which cards and found rook to
f3 stuff like it six doesn't work
because I cancelled it take yeah here
you get clap completely wiped out or
here clap clap you will lose something
at the end here this is this is the only
move here again you see that having
played a five would have been quite
useful okay look f3 and now an
absolutely critical situation in this
in and one that really made me like oh
yeah but yeah let's let's have a look or
blacks alternatives here and what like
should not do is take the pawn that
doesn't work gives widen important tempo
and then e-cigs next this is actually
already winning for why the other point
is just too strong this is also pretty
easily discarded for players of that
level I think the black choice is mainly
between two moles get the get rid of the
night click on c5 just get rid of that
annoying piece or play Bishop g6 and
keep the tension and this is the move
that the computer suggests and it is
much more fighting much more unbalanced
that say that Bishop takes d5 here why
probably will capture and play this
position yeah the thing is this is not
easy to play with black own arm easy to
play it's not easy to decide to play
that because you probably are worried
about the youporn however this pawn is
stopped quite reliably by a by the rook
and Bishop controlling that square so
while it's not just promoting this pawn
um the whole situation is really quite
unclear the computers like black but it
is not a totally conclusive evaluation
it's just like a fraction of a pawn this
is the fighting continuation in a way
what kayaking did is he took this night
which really made me as I said off
because with this black basic clay and
gives up any hope to win the game if Y
plays the place well and just again gets
into some kind of passive stance and
just to cool things it's funny that this
is actually some kind of a mirror image
you had the night on c5 got taken by the
bishop on a seven and in-game form
correctly with white played Bishop a 2
takes you farther the pawn structure on
the Queen
it's just about the same funny funny
parallel here yeah rupee and why am I
saying that this is such a one-sided
position may only white can do something
yeah let's have a look at we can put in
a couple of more moves like this here
those two bonds that black has they are
basically worthless the people on will
never move in this game and the D porn
is this serious ism reliably located in
this position if white gets in g-form
let's paint at g4 f4 f5 then he will win
basically if he gets all this moves in
he will win the game with the
steamroller on the kingside watch it has
a huge majority have four against two
and if you get it rolling a black were
just being just be an ya steamrolled it
won't be won't be pretty the thing is
however PS this bishop on this diagonal
which initiates a good blockade this is
a little bit reminiscent of the Berlin
Wall ending and where the suspicion
often stops the white pawns as well but
if anybody can do something is white
it's pretty one-sided and gap this is
kind of I don't really like such
decisions and I mean if you you are the
challenger for the world child shouldn't
you like try to do something a bit more
actively with Bishop g6 you could it
could have gone for something a little
bit more fighting I mean yes to win a
game after all and here he just them
again is putting his money on okay I can
defend this but it's a pure defense okay
rook to f8 look at three and we have a
look trade now and yeah so here White's
goal is to advance those pawns in an
organized way so that it wouldn't be
good to just that push them quickly then
you would just weaken your own position
but if white gets this on the way in an
organized fashion to get us here
and so on then he will be in great shape
however once g4 and f4 is played we
should not forget about the possibility
of black plan g 6 and keeping a blockade
or f5 fan this is the general outline
now now why should gain the space and
black should defend flexibly and what we
have to say however what ke aki now is
doing is extremely well from you are
extremely good yeah he played this
extremely well and we will see with what
yeah back and forth a five probably
played to put this porn out of a
potential attacker if the Queen enters
it could attack the porn from a five if
I was more safe and the drawback of this
move is that white is giving up on on
this long-term actioner that the king
could enter in and some end games this
could be an idea yeah now we seek I
Atkins idea king of eight this is now
very well played by the Challenger he
found a great idea the king is coming
over to the queenside Carlton is
approving a little bit and now he played
g5 on move 34 that was not an easy
decision really they are like six moves
to the time control with just eight
minutes left a little bit more before he
started to consider the move and it was
a difficult decision when I was watching
this I couldn't really make my mind up
if I would go g5 here or not um it is a
good decision it turns out but I wasn't
sure at all during the during the
broadcast because it also potentially
allows white some some yeah some some
ways to attack the pawns however it is
still a silly good idea because this is
difficult to get in and we'll see after
a couple of moves Andruw be too by
Carlton when over here and the king went
to see eight and gathered now he played
here g4 and
this is probably not leading to anything
I mean with hindsight you probably
should them recommend then why it just
days after g4 and black actually get
some some chances which is immediately
coming into play with age five yeah so
as I said it's a it's a one-sided
position that only white can try
something but with black having defended
that well yet this and this was pretty
strong here is probably roughly equal
yeah what cannot really do do something
substantial so it was a position where
in precise play certainly could have
black into huge trouble but you again
defended this very well yeah g4 age five
and here white needs to start to worry a
little bit because the H file might open
up black cards and went to Queen d2
group g7 King g3 yeah this move is
probably not that great but yeah it's um
it's it's move 40 right and we have
another move that so it's probably a
little bit questionable one thing I
wanted to show us by the way I forgot
about it I have it in my notes and black
here instead of going group which is
seven which especially considering its
move 39 it's very understandable it
could have opened up the position
immediately yeah something like this now
and probably this ends in nothing much
something like that is probably going to
be a draw I think this is okay keeping
the tension yeah King g3 is probably
with hindsight not all that great but I
mean it shouldn't lose or anything but
it doesn't really help bite either rook
g8 waiting move on move 40 and queen age
six was possible
let's move that the engines also like
and yeah the idea is to take now and
play Queen age four but it seems that
white ultimately should be okay with
Luke age too even though it is not easy
at all to play I mean this is this real
crown it's not particularly actively
placed and something like deform
requires extreme precision from white
where again Bishop g5 comes look at
seven of those kind of ideas Black has
excellent compensation for the pawn as
well we will see something quite similar
in the game but it's it's kind of you
know if you analyze such a possibility
away with Doug for 20 minutes he had
like a minute to decide and if you have
a minute and move like group changes
making perfect sense yeah another
capture a funny moment here and cards
now played the move Kim G to relatively
quickly and it's kind of a it looks at
the back back and for them and the hand
he hit here explained what happened to
him and this is a funny explanation I
think because he said that um he is he
had forgotten to write down a move yeah
they have to end a they keep normal
score sheets like like they're all doing
even in the lowest possible leak or in
junior tournament it's the same thing
also in the world championship match
they keep score sir on a piece of paper
and he had somewhat forgotten to write
down a move yeah so he was when his the
scoresheet he was on move 39 now I'd had
to make more 40 not move 41 and somehow
when he got the time added afternoon for
tea but it confused him and he said that
just to make sure okay i'll make it
relatively quick move now and played
this King g2 and this could have led
into some really really substantial
promise and we'll see now let's go ahead
to the next page
and yeah I probably should play
something that goog h2 but it's um yeah
this is this one this is also a little
bit better for black now here because
there is this possibility to open up for
black whenever he wishes um and it's
really not obvious what white what why
should do still it's better than the
game Kings you too and so what happened
now black took on g4 taking with the
edge pawn and you cannot do this by the
way that that just leaves us what do I
have here yeah g4 is the thing yeah
clearing this square for Bishop g5 check
like clap this is a key idea with the
absolutely brutal threat group takes h3
so yeah something like that is check
check check mate yes it's a mate so very
very problematic for watchin it's
probably lost the engine wants to do
this and you can to get this position
you know something went terribly wrong
for for white so he has to take with
them with the age porn and yeah critical
situation again black now um has
basically 22 moves he can try to to
start doubling on the age file I try to
get queen age one in something like that
what he can play the game move which is
the most deform the clearance move
giving up this is Pawn that probably
will never promote anyway and give the
black Bishop access to d5 red eyes the
White King those two moves come into
consideration after Queen age 6 why
probably will go here to locate this
this deep on
this basic claim keeps the bishop out of
the game of course you can imagine that
like somewhat in summer later Tom could
play like this but this is rather yeah
that takes time yeah and okay first of
all let go of course go on to the H file
let's let's have a look their age 8 and
I'll clean edge for Kiev one that is my
line group f8 key to look at for this
kind of thing this is quite
uncomfortable for what quite obviously
other rookies invading but on the other
hand it is fairly difficult to imagine
that black can win this without the
bishop somehow I mean it's not like the
bishop is doing nothing it locates the
spawn and can potentially sacrifice but
if you compare this to deform I think
from a human player's perspective d 4
makes I mean that makes perfect sense
and you include this Bishop activated
and the pawn is not that valuable anyway
so this makes perfect sense for a human
player I think it's the best move
actually just just give the pawn away
activate and also white is now posted
with a problem how do you recapture can
take with the bishop or with the Queen
council took with the Queen and yeah
this is this is probably wrong but
playing this position absolutely is
absolutely a dreadful for wide by now
it's really uncomfortable to play if you
take with the bishop um Queen h7 is what
I looked at Kings you one yeah you have
to get this prepare this kind of things
Queen age three Queenie to this is more
or less forced and yeah black now is
this just just pressing am NOT here and
then Bishop t5 I've got them and this
this is the main line off of the engine
Bishop see 355 Google edge to Queen
takes and in this position
wyd might hold up but it's not fun still
not fun and you you have to get that
fine the first place it's for a
practical point of view also very very
problematic to play Queen takes seems a
little bit seems worse actually even
though completely conclusive it is not
first we have to check now what did ki
can do now if you say Bishop g5 you're
right yeah it's the absolutely obvious
looking move it turns out however that
it probably is not the best move and
this is a yeah this is a bit computer
chess right the computer does not want
to play the natural looking move Bishop
t5 but rather wants to go into the age
file first and this leads to now White
has to dodge bullet after bullet I am I
really think that this would have
wonderful black in this game in a
practical game I don't see anybody
defending this position it starts here
white only has one move that does not
get annihilated immediately squinter you
form queen age 6 for example I mean the
next let's look at one move here this is
something that that is possible between
age six just to show how quickly it can
go go downhill it's just it's just
pretty bad so here um yeah so Queenie
force that only move that that then work
somewhat and now we get a position like
that but should be fine and some
something like that this is the main
line of the engine and I mean maybe
objectively like objectively is wrong
but if you take us at the mathematical
problem it may be wide will hold the
thing is that here you
have to be skeptical or you have to dig
relatively deep because the opposite
colored bishops they actually provide
black here with those attacking chances
but they also give white exit strategy
is there to like simplify to an ending
two points down that are still a draw
this is easily possible for example if
we imagine an ending just with bishops
white wood in in most cases easily draw
if we let's say black has those four
pawns and white only has a and C porn
yeah this would probably easily draw
because you can't put a bishop on b6 a
king on like here and you will draw it's
a fortress um so it's not totally clear
if black object of here in co or not
it's something languages that you would
need to analyze some with the engine
quite extensively however in a practical
game this is hell for what I mean you
kind of then there are all kinds of all
kinds of minds you can step onto and
just boom you're toast yeah and I think
this would have been extremely awkward
yeah can I can play this natural move
and I think what I read is that he that
he noticed yeah while cards now was
considering his studies choice that he
noticed that drew cage it probably would
have been better but this is not
something I mean where you can criticize
them all that much he's six now played
by by Karl this is the most natural move
and it probably is sufficient to get
back get white back into the into this
position computers want to go here and
and and give 000 funny enough um they
gather calculate deeply enough to see
that it's however still quite scary
looking up like ants this entry idea
computer say it's the draw but i think
the continuation chosen by the world
champion is completely understand
when you want to get rid of this pawn to
open up the position a little bit and
maybe give some color to play if you
imagine the white queen coming here for
example or later we'll see that Dookie
to e5 is coming so you open up and maybe
you can get in the black skin so taken
of course King g3 this is a good
coordination move maybe allowing for
gage to this is a I think probably the
last moment we're kayaking could have
tested Carlin a little bit more I think
King b8 intending to get the King out of
all of this would have been still quite
awkward because here it's not and there
is no clear path now to to a draw I mean
the White King is still more insecure
it's active difficult to analyze this
position because they are quite a number
of possibilities I think the practical
chances here for black would be still
quite high it's not not fun to play
really not he went Queen e7 however many
others introduces this idea for example
but this was a good reply herba cards
and the ideas to play rook h8 get rid of
one rook if a rook is traded this is not
going to be that difficult to draw yeah
there's simply the firepower is reduced
of black as an attacker and so this is a
very helpful thing if you can get it in
yeah Queen f7 now was played to take a
three this was an old tractor checking
and forcing a form then this position
here is really really yeah difficult
difficult to play that was an
opportunity a 4k I can to play for wind
locket or costs but here you have to see
that okay the White King is open but
don't underestimate the Jeep ones here
that they can be tricky especially if
somehow yeah the white white king um
it's not getting mated and then those
poles can be a huge factor as the King
supports them so this is a
very risky decision and I understand
that he didn't want to go there and yet
so Queen f7 which somehow the software
does not want to play out hmm maybe I'm
on for too long here let me check yeah
probably what's going on here now I
software crashed that's crazy but that's
crazy in the middle of recording what
the heck with it okay huh that's weird
let's try again
Oh actually have a general internet
issue that's funny oh wow I'm sorry
about the skillet I thought it would be
easily fixed here yeah you know I've got
some some guys here and not not ironmen
my oven olivion come on have a couple of
apartments him and they they change the
electricity of the doorbells and maybe
they they turned off something and my my
ruta got rebooted or something I have to
probably put them can I do that actually
put the moves on the board and they are
just a couple of moves left to play yeah
Queen Queen f7 come on hey Queen f7 now
I can't think I can just put them on the
board and Queen f7 was played by
kayaking attacking the pawn and now
cards manage to go F for him yeah takes
clap greene takes yeah and here the
worst is definitely over the black king
is also somewhat open now i know that
was one of my idea to put it i cannot
draw anymore put the one a seven or
eight um yeah I think this is what comes
now is fairly in fairly logical and
black shouldn't trade yeah that would be
unpleasant play against the Jeep on so i
put the queen here keep it on the board
and now this is also very logical
intending rookie five or g5 for the
trade souk f5 yeah look at eight and
after age seven why definitely had
secured the draw funny move you know
black Queen cannot remove that is made
on c7 so we have have this one and now
Ruby form did force the rook trade and
here they agreed to draw yeah a position
like that is just completely completely
data like it's cooking up with a king
more like you're not wrong way to with
bishop and kingdom stop the Jeep on so
it's a draw yeah a very good fighting
game again where
I think I can probably missed
opportunities I'm not probably he did
miss some opportunities but it all
wasn't trivial it's not like they that
there's something super easy that that
he missed um yeah countin I'm had a good
position of thing before the time
control but it didn't feel it was not
obvious how to improve and look one side
but it is difficult to improve
especially considering how good kayaking
played yet bringing the king over g5
seemed to be a very good plan so when I
think a good game Carson was a bit
sloppy in there with the if you really
screwed it up with the squashy that
that's a that's pretty annoying at to
get into and to such a troublesome
situation so because you forgot to write
a news down um so that was game 5 game 6
is played on November eighteenth Friday
the sea will kayak in his his right in
this game and he would have also white
in game 7 they switched the Collins damn
so they're two whites now for the
Challenger and this will be certainly
kina really be able to maybe score with
the white pieces or what would happen um
kayaking really was extremely I think
unimpressive in the opening so far he
was usually worse and couldn't get
anything great in so maybe he will do
something with those two white games now
yeah thanks a lot for watching guys bye
bye